THE ASSEMBLY IS
NOW IN SESSION. WE. MEMBERS WE
ARE HAVING TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES BEAR WITH US WE'RE
WORKING OUT THE MICROPHONE
SITUATION. I'M HAVING FLASHBACKS
TO MY DJ DAYS. THE ASSEMBLY IS
NOW IN SESSION THANK YOU MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RACE NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM. SERGEANTS
AT ARMS WILL PREPARE THE CHAMBER
AND BRING IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AND THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
. WAIT ON THE CLERK. MISTER
CLARK. THE MICROPHONE IS YOURS.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA BARRICADE
HAND BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BONTA
BRIAN BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHEN CHOI COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY
DAVIES FLORA FONG FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA KILEY
BLACKY LEE LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA. MULLIN UCHI THIS AREA
WHEN O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS LOOSE REEBOKS
ROBERT. RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH STONE
THING CALAVERAS BE APPROVED BY A
VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER. MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
IMAM YASIR KHAN IMAM YASIR. IN
THE NAME OF GOD. THE MOST
GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL.
ALMIGHTY GOD. WE'RE STANDING
HERE WITH OUR HEADS BOWED AND
HEARTS PRESENTED TO YOU. FOR YOU
TO GRACE US WITH YOUR MERCY. SO
WE CAN BE THE SOURCE OF MERCY
FOR OTHERS. AND THE LIVES OF THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. CONTINUE TO BLESS US
WITH WORRY AND CONCERN FOR
OTHERS. SO WE CAN MAKE DECISIONS
FOR THIS YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWO
. THAT ARE FULL OF POSITIVITY
LOVE AND COMPASSION FOR OTHERS I
MEAN. THANK YOU BY MISTER YES
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
RUBIO. THANK YOU MEMBERS IT'S MY
HONOR TO LEAD YOU ON THE FLAG
SALUTE TO ON OUR FIRST DAY OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO PLEASE REPEAT
AFTER ME. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG. OF THE. THANK YOU MAY
BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
ASSEMBLY MEDIT LEVIN THIRTY AM
THE AUDIBLE KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER
PRO TEMPORE THE ASSEMBLY
PRESIDING CHIEF LOOKS THE PART
OF THE DANCE READING FOR DAVID
WOMAN READING ROLL CALL THE ROLL
WAS CALLED QUORUM CALL OF THE
ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE
MORE QUORUM CALL THE ASSEMBLY
MOTION CARRY TIME ELEVEN FORTY
SEVEN AM. SPEAKER PRO TEM DIRECT
THE SERGEANT ARMS CLOSE THE
DOORS AND BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS QUORUM PRESENT TWELVE
ELEVEN PM SPEAK BOTTOM ON THE
CLEAR THE FORM OF THE ASSEMBLY
PRESENT ROLE SIMPLY DIDN'T
FOLLOWING ANSWER TO THE NAMES
SEVEN NINE AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA
OKAY HAND BEEN IT BERMAN.
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA BRIAN. BURKE CALDERON
CARRILLO. MS REYES MOVES AND
MISS WALDRON SECONDS OF THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH. THANK
YOU DAVID PRESENTATIONS OF
PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE OF BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE- TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. BIZRATE'S YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE. TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS BONTA RAMOS
REYES AND WAR TO SPEAK ON IN THE
GERMAN AND MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. FOR SOON TO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO COMMITTEE. AB
ONE THIRTEEN BURNER
BOERNER HORVATH WITH FROM THE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE TO THE
REVENUE AND TAXATION COMMITTEE.
EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY FIVE HOLDEN
FROM THE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE. EIGHTY NINE TWENTY
NINE LEVINE FROM THE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTED TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE. AB TWELVE TWENTY
SEVEN LOVETT LEVINE. FROM THE
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE
TO THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE AB FOURTEEN NINETY
EIGHT LOW FROM THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE TO THE BUSINESS OF
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE. SB NINE
SB TWO OH SEVEN DOLLY FROM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE. AGAIN
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FIFTY SIX TO ALLOW THE FOLLOWING
COMMITTEES TO NOTICE BILLS
PENDING RE REFERRAL. TO ALLOW
THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE TO NOTICE AB TWO
NINETY FOUR SANTIAGO. FOR THEIR
TUESDAY JANUARY ELEVEN HEARING.
PENDING REFERRAL FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE. AND TO
ALLOW THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO
NOTICE AB THREE TWO ONE BY
VOTERS. FOR THEIR WEDNESDAY
JANUARY TWELVE HEARING. PENDING
REFERRAL FROM THE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE AND THAT TO ALLOW THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE TO
NOTICE AB SIX SEVEN TWO.
CRISTINA GARCIA. AB SIX EIGHTY
TO BLOOM AB NINE ONE SIX SOLACE.
AB FOURTEEN FORTY FIVE LEVINE.
AB FIFTEEN FORTY THREE BLUMEN AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY ONE SANTIAGO. FOR
THEIR HEARING. ON JANUARY
TWELFTH PENDING REFERRAL FROM
THE HOUSING COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE. AND TO
ALLOW THEM TO ALSO NOTICED AB
THIRTEEN OH SEVEN CERVANTES. FOR
THE SAME HEARING PENDING
REFERRAL FROM THE ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. MEMBERS. MEMBERS PLEASE DIRECT YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. HOW'S THAT OKAY
THANK YOU MISTER BRYANT WELCOME
BACK MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS GOOD
TO SEE EVERYBODY HAPPY NEW YEAR
LET'S GET TO WORK. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
GOVERNOR'S VETOES ITEMS SHALL BE
CONTINUED. RECONSIDERATION ITEMS
ON RECONSIDERATION SHALL BE
CONTINUED. ON ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE ITEMS FORTY SEVEN
AND FORTY EIGHT. PASS AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS LIKE YOU HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
SPECIAL ANNOUNCEMENT AFTER
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY SO I ASK
THAT MEMBERS PLEASE STAY IN THE
CHAMBER. PLEASE STAY ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR WE ARE MOVING TO
A GERMAN TO MEMORIES. IN MEMORY
AND I WOULD ASK THAT MEMBERS
PLEASE. STAY ON THE FLOOR. IN
THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
GERMAN TO MEMORY. THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS WERE GRANTED PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MISBAH
TOUGH YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR
DESK. THANK YOU I RISE TODAY IN
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY OF MISS
WILMA CHAN OUR COLLEAGUE MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ON NOVEMBER
FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE WERE
SHOCKED TO HEAR THE NEWS REPORTS
ABOUT THE SUDDEN AND TRAGIC
PASSING OF THE HONORABLE WOMAN
CHAN I RISE TODAY WITH A HEAVY
HEART AND ASK THAT YOU JOIN ME
IN A DURING IN HER MEMORY. WILMA
WAS A SITTING MEMBER O THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS REPRESENTING
DISTRICT THREE IN THE EAST BAY
EARLIER DURING HER CAREER OF
MEMBER OF THIS HOUSE SHE
REPRESENTED THE CITY OF OAKLAND
AND THE SIXTH SIXTEENTH DISTRICT
FROM 200-022-0006 TO ASSEMBLY
SPEAKERS INCLUDING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAN AS PART OF THEIR
LEADERSHIP TEAM. FOR THE
200-012-2000 TWO SESSIONS
SPEAKER ROBERT HERTZBERG
APPOINTED HER MAJORITY WHIP FOR
THE 200-032-2000 FOUR
LEGISLATIVE SEASON SESSION
SPEAKER HERB WESSON JUNIOR
APPOINTED HER AS MAJORITY LEADER
WITH DISAPPOINTMENT WILMA CHAN
BECAME THE ASSEMBLY'S FIRST
ASIAN AMERICAN AND THE FIRST
WOMAN APPOINTED AS MAJORITY
LEADER IT'S BEEN SIXTEEN YEARS
SINCE WILMA CHAN DEPARTED FROM
THIS ASSEMBLY WE NOW SERVE IN A
TIME OUR DIVERSITY AND FRST I
SEEN AS A STRING AND THE STRING
OF HER VISION. WAS THAT HAS
CONSTITUENTS WERE SECOND TO NONE
MISTRANSLATED SEE IN HER FOR
DECADES OF PUBLIC SERVICE IS
THAT SHE MODELED HOW AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL CAN BRING TANGIBLE
IMPROVEMENTS FOR THE DAY DATE TO
THE DAY TO DAY LIVES OF HER
CONSTITUENTS IN FACT WHEN SHE
WAS LOOKING TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT ME SHE SAID I WILL STAND
FOR YOU. BECAUSE I KNOW THAT YOU
WILL STAND FOR SOMETHING. THE
CHAD MADE IT HER LIFE'S TO FIGHT
FOR ACCESSIBLE QUALITY HEALTH
CARE HOUSING AND ESSENTIAL
SERVICES FOR WOMEN CHILDREN
SENIORS. AND IMMIGRANTS. HER
WORK EMBODIED THE BEST IDEALS OF
LEADERSHIP AND PUBLIC SERVICE.
AND HER LEGACY WILL CONTINUE TO
REVERBERATE FOR GENERATIONS TO
COME. WILMA WAS A LEADER A
MENTOR AN ARCHETYPE AND A
FRIEND. SHE NOT ONLY INSPIRED
SHE ALSO WORKED CLOSELY WITH
MANY OF US HERE NOW THIS
CHAMBER. BOTH MEMBER AND SUPPORT
. IT WOULD BE EASY TO SAY. THE
TO LIST WOMAN'S THE POTENTIAL IS
TO ACHIEVEMENTS. FOOD FOR THE
HUNGRY HOMES FOR THE
UNHEALTHIEST ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE FOR THE UNINSURED. AND
UNDERINSURED A VOICE FOR THE
UNHEARD IT IS MORE DIFFICULT TO
MOURN THE LOSS OF OUR COLLEAGUE.
FALL UNDER IN HER MEMORY THROUGH
A COMMITMENT TO SERVICE THAT
REFLECTS HOW SHE- HERSELF SERVED
. AS WE EMBARK ON ANOTHER
SESSION MARKED BY THE POOL BUT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC I THANK YOU
FOR SHARING THIS MOMENT TO HONOR
AN AMAZING FEARS AND HUMBLE
WARRIOR. HERE WITH US TODAY SOME
OF THE WOMAN'S PARENTS STAFF
ALSO KNOWN AS THE DEVOTED
CHAMPLIN. THE PROVIDER DAVE
BROWN ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THIRD DISTRICT.
REBEKAH CRISES SENIOR POLICY
ADVISOR. OFFICE OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY SUPERVISORS FOUND.
CEREMONY POLICY ADVISOR OFFICE
OF ALAMEDA COUNTY SUPERVISOR
BRITTANY BROWN. MADONSELA ONE
POLICY ADVISER OFFICE OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY SUPERVISOR DAVE BROWN. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURNMENT MY APPOINTMENT JIM.
OF THE CITY OF ALL. THE GIFT.
THANK YOU MS BONTA. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
. THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. IT IS WITH GREAT
SADNESS THAT OUR RIGHTS TO
REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURNED IN THE
MEMORY OF DR MARGARET HILL WHO
PASSED AWAY ON DECEMBER
NINETEENTH AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY
ONE. DR HILL WAS A BOARD MEMBER
AND FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE
SAMBAR DINO CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT A STRONG ADVOCATE FOR
CHILDREN A DEDICATED COMMUNITY
LEADER. AND ALWAYS WITH A WARM
HEART. DR HILL STARTED HER
EDUCATIONAL CAREER IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE. BEFORE SERVING AS A
VICE PRINCIPAL AT SAMBAR DINO
HIGH SCHOOL. AFTER A CAREER
SERVICE SHE RETIRED IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE AFTER SERVING
SIXTEEN YEARS AS A PRINCIPAL OF
SAN ANDREAS HIGH SCHOOL. SHE
RETURNED TO THE SAN MARINO
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT SCHOOLS IN
TWO THOUSAND SIX AND SERVE THEIR
INTELLIGENT LIE TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE. IN TOTAL HER CAREER IN
EDUCATION SPANS FIFTY YEARS.
SUPPORTING GENERATIONS OF SAN
MARINO SCHOOL STUDENTS. AND
COMMUNITY ACTIVISTS. THE
DISTRICT HONORED DR HILL BY
NAMING ITS BOARDROOM THE DOCTOR
MARGARET HILL COMMUNITY ROOM IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. OVER THE
YEARS SHE HAS BEEN RECOGNIZED BY
GROUPS ACROSS OUR COMMUNITY FOR
HER STRENGTH. HER SERVICE AND
HER PASSION TO UP LIFT OUR
COMMUNITY. DR HILL ALSO SERVED
AS VICE PRINCIPAL AT SERRANO
JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL WHERE MANY OF
US FROM THE INDIAN RESERVATION
ATTENDED AND WHERE SHE LIFTED US
UP TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CONTINUE
TO FOLLOW AND SECURE OUR DREAMS
. SHE LED THE SAMBAR DINO BLACK
CULTURE FOUNDATION AND MOVE
FORWARD ON COMMUNITY AWARDS WITH
THE BLACK ROSE AWARDS IN OUR
COMMUNITY. WHERE I WAS HUMBLED
TO BE HONORED WITH A BLACK ROSE
FROM DOCTOR MARGARET HILL. DR
HILL PUSHED US ALL TO ACHIEVE
OUR DREAMS NO MATTER OF OUR
CIRCUMSTANCES. DR HILL. IS A
LIFELONG INSPIRATION WHO LED A
TIRELESS FORCE TO MAKE SURE THAT
SHE LIFTED UP NOT ONLY A
COMMUNITY FROM THE BLACK
COMMUNITY BUT ALL COMMUNITY
MEMBERS IN SAMBAR DINO. AND
SHE'S ANNA MEYER LEADER IN THE
EDUCATIONAL COMMUNITY. SHE WILL
FOREVER BE REMEMBERED REMEMBER.
THE OVERALL COMMUNITY AS A WHOLE
HAS LOST A GREAT LEADER AND A
GREAT ADVOCATE AND NOW WE LOOK
TO THOSE IN THE COMMUNITY TO
LIFT UP MARGARET HILL AS WE
ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY. AND WE
LOOK TO OUR COMMUNITY AND WE
KNOW IT'S A BETTER PLACE BECAUSE
SHE GAVE SO MUCH TO OUR
COMMUNITY AND A PASSION FOR ALL
THE LIVE IN OUR AREA. THANK YOU
MYSTERON HOUSE MS RADIUS YOU TWO
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I TO RISE. REQUEST THE RETURN OF
THE MEMORY OF DR MARGARET HILL.
MARGARET WAS A LOCAL LEADER HAS
MY COLLEAGUES MENTIONED LOCAL
LEADER IN SAMBAR TO DINO SHE
SERVED OUR COMMUNITY AS A BOARD
MEMBER AND PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
STAMINA DINO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. HE WAS A STAUNCH
PROPONENT OF EMPOWERING STUDENTS
THROUGH EDUCATION. MENTORSHIP.
MARGARET HILL SERVED IN VARIOUS
ROLES AS AN EDUCATOR AND AN
ADMINISTRATOR. AT THE PLEASURE
OF KNOWING MARGARET WAS A
DIFFERENT. OUR COMMUNITY IS IN
MOURNING HER PASSING AND WITH
HER PASSING WE HAVE ALL LOST IN
MENTOR ENCOURAGER AND EDUCATOR A
LEADER AND AUTHOR THE
CONFIDANTE. FRIEND AND ALSO THE
ORGANIZER OF THE BEST MOM MOB
EVER. SHE DID THIS AT THE
BEGINNING OF EVERY SCHOOL YEAR
WHERE SHE WOULD GET MANY OF US
IN THE COMMUNITY TO COME AND
WELCOME THE STUDENTS AS THEY
CAME TO SCHOOL ON THEIR FIRST
DAY. SHE WAS AN ICON IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND CHANGE THE LIVES
OF SO MANY STUDENTS OVER THE
YEARS. SHE LOVED THE STUDENTS
AND GAVE THEM HER ALL. SHE
PROVIDED ENCOURAGEMENT SUPPORT
FOR FRIENDS AND TO THE COMMUNITY
AS A WHOLE. MARGARET'S
DEDICATION WAS TRULY INSPIRING
AND I KNOW HER LEGACY WILL LIVE
ON NOT ONLY THROUGH THE AWARD
SHE IS EARNED THROUGH THE YEARS.
BUT ALSO THROUGH THE SUCCESS SHE
HAS HAD IN BETTERING THE LIVES
OF COUNTLESS STUDENTS. WE WILL
MISS HER DEARLY. MAY SHE REST IN
GOD'S PERFECT PEACE AND MAY SHE
LIVE AND LIVE ON IN OUR MEMORIES
AND IN HER DEDICATION TO SERVE
STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE I ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU MS REYES. MISTER WAR
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER IT'S WITH A HEAVY
HEART THAT I RISE TODAY TO
RETURN IN THE MEMORY OF GREG
BLOCK GREG PASSES NOVEMBER AFTER
A COURAGEOUS BATTLE WITH CANCER
HE WOULD BE FIFTY ONE THIS WEEK.
I HAD THE PLEASURE OF KNOWING
AND WORKING WITH GREG FIRST OF
HIS TIME AS THE CHIEF
COMMUNICATIONS OFFICER AT SAN
DIEGO STATE A DECADE AGO AND
THEN AGAIN AS A SENIOR PRESS
SECRETARY FOR SAN DIEGO'S MAYOR
WHILE I WAS ON CITY COUNCIL HE
WAS A PROUD NINETEEN NINETY FIVE
ALUMNI OF SDSU WHERE YOU EARNED
A DEGREE IN JOURNALISM AND
WORKED AS A SPORTS WRITER FOR
THE STUDENT NEWSPAPER THE DAILY
AZTEC. HE LOVED THE SDSU
COMMUNITY AND HE LOVED OUR CITY.
AND HE WAS CONSTANTLY POSITIVE
AND OPTIMISTIC ABOUT TACKLING
OUR BIGGEST CHALLENGES. I SAW
THIS FIRST HAND WORKING WITH HIM
FOR HIS COMMITMENT TO HELP TURN
AROUND. FOR STRATEGIES TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS. HE WAS A
FRIEND AND A MENTOR TO SO MANY
HE LISTENED. HE ENCOURAGED
ANYONE TO MAKE GOVERNMENT
BETTER. MORE IMPORTANTLY HE WAS
A COMMITTED FAMILY MAN. COACHING
AND ENGAGE WITH THE UPBRINGING
OF HIS TWO CHILDREN. WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THE SAN DIEGO
COMMUNITY COMING TOGETHER AND
ESTABLISHING A SCHOLARSHIP FOR
JOURNALISM JOURNALISM AT SDSU IN
HIS NAME. GREG REMINDS US OF THE
DIFFERENCE THAT ONE PERSON CAN
TRULY MAKE AND IS LOVING MEMORY
CONTINUES TO LIVE THROUGH ALL
THE HIM THAT. I'D LIKE TO BUY MY
NEIGHBOR OR COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ TO OFFER REMARKS
AS WELL. LASSIE PLEASE JOIN US
IN KEEPING GREG. HIS WIFE RACHEL
THEIR CHILDREN AND IMMEDIATE
FAMILY IN YOUR THOUGHTS AS WE
JOURNEY MEMORY OF OUR FRIEND
GREG BLOCK. SOME NEVER GONZALEZ
. L. HOW MUCH. I ALSO RISE-
TESTU CHURNED IN MEMORY MY
FRIEND GREG BLOCK IDEA HAD THE
GREAT OPPORTUNITY THE NIGHT
BEFORE MY MASTECTOMY TO SIT WITH
GREAT AS HE KNEW HE WAS DYING OF
CANCER AND HIS SPIRIT CONTINUED
EVEN IN THAT MOMENT IN PROVIDING
OF US WILL HOPEFULLY NEVER HAVE
TO FACE AN AFRICAN OUR OWN
MORTALITY RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT NOW
HI. I KNOW HE LEAVES A LEGACY IN
SAN DIEGO A PERSONAL ONE FOR
THOSE OF US WHO KNEW HIM BUT ONE
FOR THE ENTIRE CITY THAT HE WAS
ABLE TO PROVIDE- SO MUCH OF IT
IN THE MIDDLE OF SO MANY OF THE
BIG THINGS THAT HAPPEN IN SAN
DIEGO OVER THE LAST FEW DECADES.
I KNOW HE WILL BE MISSED-
INCREDIBLY IN RT IS BY HIS WIFE
RACHEL WHO IS A GOOD FRIEND OF
MINE AS WELL AS BY HIS CHILDREN
GEORGIAN BAND- HIS SON BEN IN
FACT TODAY WENT BACK TO SCHOOL
AT UP NORTH AND- GEORGIA
FINISHED HIGH SCHOOL ALL WITHOUT
THEIR FATHER- BUT HOPEFULLY THE
WORK WE'VE DONE AND CONTINUE
DOING SAN DIEGO TO HOLD ON TO
HIS MEMORY WILL ALLOW THEM TO
KNOW WHAT A GREAT MAN HE TRULY
WAS AND HOW MUCH OF AN IMPACT HE
HAD ON THE ENTIRE REGION OF SAN
DIEGO. I SIGNATURE IN HIS MEMORY
. THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ THANK
YOU MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE
NAMES OF DEATHS REPORTED IN THE
JOURNAL. ALL REQUEST TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
MEMBERS WE HAVE AN ANNOUNCEMENT
I WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE. MS
GONZALEZ FLETCHER DESK FOR YOUR
ANNOUNCEMENT. TO LEARN IN THIS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. I
RISE- FIRST OF ALL I'M TO. VIED
A VERY DIRECT THANK YOU TO ALL
OF YOU- FOR YOUR TREMENDOUS LOVE
AND SUPPORT OVER THE LAST FEW
MONTHS IF THEY DON'T WITH BREAST
CANCER DIAGNOSIS I LEFT THE
FLOOR THE DAY BEFORE. TWO DAYS
BEFORE THE END OF SESSION- WITH
A LOT OF GOOD WISHES AND I NEVER
STOPPED AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
EVERYTHING THAT SO MANY OF YOU
DID WHETHER IT WAS TAX OUR PHONE
CALLS AND FLOWERS AND GIFTS IN.
A LOT OF WINE- IN EVEN. A
HOMEMADE MEAL OR TWO FROM SOME
OF MY FEMALE COLLEAGUES SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT I'M
EXCITED TO BE CANCER FREE
RECONSTRUCTED AND HEALTHY- AND I
WAS OVERWHELMED BY THE SUPPORT
THAT I RECEIVED. BUT RETURNING
TO FLOOR TODAY IS A BITTERSWEET
FOR ME BECAUSE IT'S THE LAST DAY
WELL SIR WITH ALL OF YOU. ON
DECEMBER THIRTY FIVE OFFERED A
POSITION WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION WHICH ONCE I
ACCEPT WILL ALLOW ME TO
TRANSITION PERIOD TO TAKE THE
REINS OF THE ORGANIZATION IN
JULY. THE FOURTEENTH SERVICE
CAPACITY DOESN'T COME UP BUT
EVERY FEW DECADES AND IF I THINK
YOU ALL KNOW SERVING WORKING
CALIFORNIANS IT'S MY SINGULAR
PRIORITY VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND IT JUST HAPPENED
TO COME AT A TIME THAT MAKES
LIFE A LITTLE BIT. EASIER FOR. A
FEW OF US. WHEN I BECAME
CHAIRMAN PERFORATIONS COMMITTEE
WE PLACED A SIGN OUTSIDE AND I
THINK MOST OF YOU HAVE READ IT
SITTING THERE WAITING FOR YOUR
MEETING IT SAYS THE MOST AMOUNT
OF GOOD FOR THE MOST AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE I HOPE WE ACCOMPLISH THAT
AND I EXPECT THAT THIS
INSTITUTION WILL CONTINUE TO
SEEK TO ACCOMPLISH THAT. IT IS
WHAT WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE HERE
DOING. BUT IT'S JUST NOT THROUGH
THE ELECTED LEADERS THAT THOSE
WORDS BECOME TRUTH. IT'S THROUGH
INCREDIBLE HARD WORK OF STAFF
THAT MAKE THIS BUILDING RUN. I'D
BE REMISS TO NOT SAY A HUGE
THANK YOU. STARTING WITH THIRTY
GS CUSTODIAL CREW WHO LITERALLY
CLEAN UP AFTER US. THE CHIEF
CLERK SUE PARKER AND HER STAFF
MAKE SURE EVERYTHING WE DO IS
LEGITIMATE. CHIEF BUCKLEY AND
HER STAFF WHO KEPT THE FAITH AND
I KNOW ME PERSONALLY HAVE BEEN
AT MY BECK AND CALL FAR TOO MANY
TIMES AND I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT.
BUT THEY'VE ALWAYS ON CAMPUS.
WHERE FAITH AND WHERE WE NEEDED
TO GO. COURSE ALL THE
LEGISLATIVE STAFF. IN THE
SPEAKER STAFF. WHO WE KNOW. DO
MOST OF THE HARD WORK BEHIND THE
SCENES THERE ARE NO WORDS I
COULD HAVE EVER EXPRESSED MY OWN
PERSONAL STAFF IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS STAFF WHO HAVE
BEEN ABSOLUTELY PHENOMENAL AND-
I WOULD ARGUE THAT SOME OF THE
BEST IN. THIS BUILDING. THE
BUILDING ACROSS THE STREET I
GUESS NOW BUT TRULY TIRELESS.
AND TO ALL OF YOU- SOME OF WHOM
I MET FOR THE FIRST TIME ON THE
FLOOR I WILL MISS YOU. I WON'T
BE FAR- BUT SOME OF YOU TO BE AT
LEAST WHO I'VE KNOWN FOR DECADES
AND- ARE SOME OF MY CLOSEST
FRIENDS- I'M SORRY THIS IS COME
SO SUDDEN AND I DIDN'T GIVE YOU
WARNING BUT- SOMETIMES THAT
HAPPENS. I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL
FOR THE GOOD WORK YOU'VE DONE IN
THE WORK WE'VE DONE TOGETHER. I
WOULD THINK THE SHERATON CAUCUS
IN MY HOUSE THE FIERCENESS. FOR
YOUR TRUE- AND DEEP FRIENDSHIPS.
I WON'T BE FAR THE GOOD NEWS IS
I WON'T BE ABLE TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT ANY A- BILLS FOR OVER A
YEAR SO BYE BYE TO THE DINNER
YOU'RE FREE OF UP PRESSURE FROM
ANY SO CALLED THE JOB. KILLER
BILLS AT LEAST. FOR NOW. THE
LAST BUT NOT. MISTER SPEAKER
BECAUSE WITHOUT SAYING. THAT
NEARLY EVERYTHING I WAS ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH AS A LEGISLATOR. IT
WAS REALLY DUE TO YOUR
LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU FOR
ENTRUSTING ME TO CHAIR THE
PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE THANK YOU
FOR BEING MY FRIEND IT'S BEEN
SUCH AN HONOR. BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PROGRESSIVE VISION AND
COMMITMENT TO TRULY DOING THE
MOST GOOD FOR THE MOST AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE EVERY SINGLE TIME. THANK
YOU FOR SHARING MY COMMITMENT TO
WORKERS. IN MOST OF ALL THANK
YOU AN ANTI FOR YOUR FRIENDSHIP
. I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THAT FRIENDSHIP. SO WITH THAT I
NEED TO. NOW GO TO MY
CONSTITUENTS HOW MUCH I LOVE
THEM ANNA. THE TRANSITION THAT
I'LL BE MAKING. AND SO ON THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND I AM A
RESPECTFULLY. RESIGN FROM THE
ASSEMBLY EFFECTIVE CLOSE OF
BUSINESS ON WEDNESDAY GOD BLESS
YOU.
MEMBERS WILL BE TWO OTHER
ANNOUNCEMENTS THE RULES
COMMITTEE WILL MEET UPON A
GERMAN AND ROOM FOR THIRTY SEVEN
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY JANUARY FOURTH CHECK IN
SESSION WEDNESDAY JANUARY FIFTH
CHECK IN SESSION THURSDAY
JANUARY SIX FOUR SESSION AT NINE
AM ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING
WILL BE PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUE SEEING
INTERNET FOR THE BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN. MISTER BLOOM MOVES AND
MISTER FLORA SECONDS THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
THURSDAY JANUARY SIXTH AT NINE
AM. AND A QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.